since 2000 the self-offing rate in the
United States has increased by 50
percent from 11 per 100 000 people to 16
per 100 000 people many would blame a
modern tech for much of this increase
people are more glued to their phones
and computers than ever before leading
to less human interactions and more
isolation resulting in higher levels of
depression and thus more self-offings
now that could very well be a factor but
something that has a much more concrete
connection is a medication called
fluoxetine or Prozac Prozac is a
medication that is supposed to treat
depression OCD panic disorders and
bulimia theoretically it is supposed to
accomplish this by increasing serotonin
levels inside the brain which seemed to
have a positive correlation with mood
emotion and sleep today Prozac is the
25th most prescribed medication with an
estimated 23 million patients within the
U.S alone so at 3 first glance Prozac
seems like a miracle medication that has
helped hundreds of millions of people
overcome the darkest parts of their
lives but what if I told you that Prozac
was actually doing the exact opposite
you see it while Prozac may be
successful at giving patients a surge of
Joy or excitement over the long term it
can actually make patients more likely
to end it all surely such a severe side
effect was an unintended consequence and
something that Eli Lilly the creators of
Prozac simply didn't discover during
their initial studies well actually
there's reports from the British medical
journal suggesting that Eli Lele not
only knew about these side effects but
that they went as far as concealing the
evidence that was suggesting this one of
their own studies found that 38 of
patients taking Prozac displayed
symptoms of agitation and aggression
while only 19 of patients taking the
placebo display the same symptoms and
this was way back in 1988 but Eli Lilly
allegedly never handed over these
findings to the FDA clinical reviewer
who was responsible for approving the
medication now this could have been an
honest mistake but when coincidence
aligns with opportunity that's rarely
the case not to mention him this is just
one of Eli Lily's many allegations and
settlements but despite the Shady
history Eli Lilly is not only doing well
they're doing phenomenal in fact their
stock is up 5x within the past five
years alone which has given them a
market cap of just over 400 billion
dollars at this point they're often
trading spots with the J J for the title
of a world's largest pharmaceutical
company
so here's how Eli Lilly managed to make
400 billion dollars worth of Blood Money
foreign
taking a look back the story of Eli
Lilly dates back to the late 1800s to a
man named Eli Lilly Eli was a Civil War
veteran having served as a Chrono during
the war he wanted to transfer the
altruistic Ambitions of the Civil War
into a company of his own only instead
of fighting slavery he would be fighting
disease and with that Eli would open up
a small laboratory in Indianapolis in
1876. Eli wasn't creating anything
groundbreaking per se he was simply
producing and selling medications that
were already on the market but thanks to
his War Legacy and a lack of big Pharma
it didn't take Eli very long to get the
people of Indianapolis behind him one of
the first medicines that Eli sold was
quinine which is used to treat malaria
this alone allowed him to reach over
four thousand dollars worth of sales by
the end of the first year alone
that's over a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars today within just three
years he would over 10x that amount of
growing to forty nine thousand dollars
in sales or over 1.3 million dollars
today
all of this extra Revenue gave Eli
plenty of Headroom to expand and invest
back into the business and that's
exactly what he would do in 1878 Eli
would hire his brother James as his
first full-time salesman and the James
would start marketing the product Across
the Nation back at home Eli was also
heavily investing into research and
development one of their first
inventions was adding fruity flavors and
sugar to their pills which made them
much more palatable and the thus far
more popular as their medicines gained
popularity Across the Nation Eli would
go ahead and formally incorporate the
company in 1881 and this marked the
beginning of Eli lele's Monumental rise
within the next 20 years Eli Lilly would
grow to over 2 000 product lines more
than 300 000 in annual sales and at
Nationwide relevance but Eli never let
the success get to his head he strongly
believed that the industry needed
ethical reform that Miracle medicine
needed to be replaced by medications
that had strong scientific backgrounds
and at mountains of evidence
these are the only types of medication
that Eli carried up until his death in
1898 and his son Josiah would uphold
this Legacy after he took over during
the early 1900s Eli Lilly would have
become masters of manufacturing which
was really the secret behind their
extraordinary reach and skill in fact
Eli Lilly was so good at manufacturing
that there would often have excess
capacity that they would sell off to
their competitors by 1917 they were
operating the largest capsule Factory in
the world producing more than 2.5
million capsules per day but with Eli's
son at the helmet it seems that this
success did get to his head as it wasn't
long until we saw the first inklings of
monopolistic anti-consumer practices and
this started with none other than
insulin
in 1921 three scientists from the
University of Toronto began working on a
treatment for diabetes which at the time
was deadly these guys would end up
developing a commercially producible
insulin which ended up winning their
main Nobel Prize Eli Lilly was watching
all of this unfold from the sidelines
and they were extremely interested in
this project from the very beginning but
to their disappointment the researchers
were extremely hesitant in regards to
working with a commercial firm they had
much more altruistic motives and were
more concerned about insulin helping
people as opposed to generating a profit
but despite this the researchers would
eventually team up with Eli Lilly when
they realized that this was the only way
to reach the skill they dreamed of and
with that Eli Lilly began selling
insulin in 1923 and they've had a
monopoly over insulin ever since in fact
to this day
sanofi and Anova nordis control 90 of
the US insulin market for the first time
Eli Lilly had a medication that people
would buy regardless of their financial
situation and this would quickly show
during the Great Depression while people
were losing their life savings companies
were going bankrupt and investors were
losing Millions yeah Lily would actually
reach record high sales of 13 million
dollars in 1932. that's the same as 287
million dollars today as you can see
with insulin Eli was starting to Veer
off their altruistic Roots but they had
yet to turn to the dark side completely
in fact throughout the next few decades
they would be involved in a few
commendable efforts starting with World
War II during the war Eli would partner
with the American Red Cross to process
plasma for wounded soldiers and by the
end of the war they would process over 2
million pints of blood which was about
20 of all of the plasmodels processed in
the United States
but their contribution to World War II
was nothing in comparison to their
contribution to polio if you pay
attention in History Class the name
Jonas Salk may ring a bell sulk is the
legend that created the polio vaccine
but not only did he create the vaccine
but he also actively chose to not patent
it so that it could reach as many people
as possible obvious reasons Hawk is
often described as a hero and rightfully
so but he didn't do it alone
Waki how to created the vaccine it still
had to be distributed to people around
the world and the first person to step
up their plate was of course Eli Lilly
but this was also one of the last
universally good activities that Eli
would participate in since then most of
their philanthropic efforts have had an
undertone of branding and marketing
which isn't the worst thing but also not
ideal but what has really given Eli a
bad rep since then is their medications
themselves
thank you
one of Eli's first controversial
medications was Darwin which came out in
the late 1950s the medication was
advertised as a mild painkiller which it
was not very effective at but what it
was effective at was getting people
addicted and that this is not too
surprising when you consider that it
falls into the opioid category by the
early 1970s these dangerous artifacts
were starting to become clear and that
non-profits like public citizens were
starting to advocate for a ban Eli would
of course try to defend Darwin claiming
that it was safer and it was addictive
than a morphine but the allegations
claimed that darvan was actually even
less effective in Aspirin in terms of
pain relief but even more effective than
the white stuff in terms of killing
people
despite this it wasn't till 2010 that
the FDA would finally ban Darwin meaning
that Eli was able to profit off darbonne
for decades at least darvan was just
addictive some of Eli's other
medications were straight up harmful
like an antibiotic called erythromycin
in the 1970s evidence emerged that this
antibiotic was toxic for the liver often
resulting in jaundice
the FDA would initially ask Eli to
discontinue their product but after
another review at Eli's request the FDA
would somehow change their mind another
Eli medication that was straight up
deadly was through synthetic estrogen
Des apparently the medication was
supposed to prevent miscarriages but it
actually just let the woman developing
cancer worse it led to their daughters
developing cancer as well a couple of
class action lawsuits were filed against
Eli but none of these really went
anywhere as Eli would just pay these
people off by settling outside of court
you would think that Eli would be more
careful after these lawsuits but they
would actually become more risk on with
an arthritis medication called oroflex
in the early 1980s dozens of people
taking oraflex would end up dying due to
liver and a kidney failure any moral
pharmaceutical company would have pause
the sale of oriflex and conduct more
testing or at least include a warning
label
but what Eli did was try to cover up the
fact that people were dying from
regulators and this is not an allegation
this is actually a fact as Eli would end
up pleading guilty but do you know what
the fine for this heinous crime was a
pitiful 25
000. usually we talk about how such
fines are nothing in comparison to what
these companies earn but 25
000 I mean that's literally something
that a lot of everyday people can afford
diabetes patients literally have to pay
more than this to Eli for insulin over a
five-year period so yeah you can take
that for what you will all of this
brings us into Eli's worst defense which
is of course Prozac in the late 1980s
Eli would launch an antidepressant
called Prozac despite allegedly having
evidence that Prozac increased the
likelihood of people self-offing when
third-party evidence came out against
Prozac Eli would launch a full-on
campaign to defend Prozac it appears
that Eli was successful at defending
Prozac but that also means that Humanity
was unsuccessful at defending our most
vulnerable and the results speak for
themselves people ending it all has
increased by 50 over the past 20 years
as hundreds of millions of people to
Prozac
foreign
Eli has battled with hundreds of
lawsuits and dozens of fines but while
this has created some friction for their
business it has by no means stopped the
damage none of this is to say that Eli
Lily is evil just because they put out
medications with side effects the
reality is that no clinical testing is
perfect and some side effects only show
up at scale so that's not a problem the
reason that Eli Lily is evil is because
they do not respond to this damage in
fact they actively tried to get away
with it they deny that their medications
are causing the damage they insist on
keeping their medications available
despite mounting evidence against them
and they even can tell evidence that
makes their medications look bad not to
mention it they also exercise
monopolistic control over much of the
pharmaceutical Market All For What well
to sell as many medications as possible
and to maximize profits over human lives
and looking at the numbers this is one
thing that Eli is extraordinarily good
at as they're headed towards becoming a
fortune Tank Company
but while they may still have an Empire
it doesn't change that their empire was
built on blood did you know about Prozac
or Eli lele's role in all of this
comment that down below also drop a like
if you agree that Eli Lilly is a truly
evil company and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
suggested video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions are
logically answered but until then I'm
Harry and I'll see you guys on the next
one